what do you mean by 70% of the story is
in the
body these are scientifically proven
facts that 70% of
communication happens in your body in
the energy of the of the body the way
you use your body the way you breathe in
your body so your body is
communicating information to the outer
world all the time whether we're
conscious or not so that's that
20% is your voice and the tonality of
your voice and then and this is strange
9 to
10% it's content now don't tell that to
a screenwriter because they would get
very upset yes written content is so
important the script is so important if
you don't have a script you don't have a
movie but um in terms of
performance it's it's really 70%
physicality 20% the voice and the tone
of the voice and then just the script
so that's why this book and the way I
work with people is I want to get their
whole bodies into
it because it will integrate everything
together so beautifully and the
performance will be Unforgettable you
don't want people to forget your
performance Mary McDonald's performance
in passion fish I will never forget
it you know and and you know and she is
an actress that you know she just goes
straight to my heart and that's true for
a lot of people they have some actors
that they keep thinking about them and
and uh and they like to see their
performing again and again and again and
again yeah that's such a strong
performance from all the actors on there
yeah oh my goodness what is one of your
favorite acting performances where the
actor owned their body their breath
their power they were
rooted yeah uh when I was in Italy I was
I would I grew up in in I was born in
Morocco we moved to Milan and I was
there and one of the first films that I
saw the two films that I saw I saw
Lawrence of
Arabia and I thought that Peter
otoul was so magnificent I had no idea
in that in that period I I knew nothing
about acting knew nothing about film but
um as a kid the only thing I wanted to
do is go back and watch this very long
mature movie you know you know I was
what I don't know N9 10 years old but I
was so moved by it and and you know it
was tremendous you know I never seen
anything like
it and so that was one performance and
then the other performance and that was
a few years
later uh it was uh 2001 Space
Odyssey I thought the the um
astronauts kir DEA most people don't
know who he is anymore but he was a
Bowman you know one of the um
astronauts he was
so attuned in some ways and so so
connected and a bit cold there was a
coldness to him him and uh the computer
hell had more warmth than
Humanity how are they doing this I mean
besides just the whole skill of the film
and you know the the Artistry of the
film I I I love that film I still
do but the uh it was new acting we had
never seen that kind of acting
before and even even the Apes you know
the um performers in the Apes
outfits uh they were not you thought
they were Apes they were primitive
people they you know they didn't seem to
me uh like costumes they seem quite real
to me and uh it it was it it really
moved me tremendously and got me
involved in film in a way that whatever
they're doing I want to do I I don't
know what they're doing but it's unusual
and it's exciting and and groundbreaking
you know I mean that the movie was so
groundbreaking when I saw it and if
you've watched uh Ruben oland's the
square Terry notary has an amazing scene
where he plays yes Terry know Ashley
actually studied Alexander with me oh
okay he was a student at UCLA but I've
admired his uh work his movement work
and uh working with Apes he does a lot
of that work and he's brilliant
brilliant yeah brilliant brilliant actor
and Brilliant um
mover and I believe he's using every
part of his being I mean he became this
this Predator ape and it's absolutely
it's an I invite everyone to watch that
scene especially the whole movie I love
uh but that scene has got some very
interesting uh thoughts on class and and
just sort of the bystandard effect and
these different things that happen and
uh it's fascinating yeah I agree I agree
what has been some of the most
challenging roles you've had to take on
as a teacher well as a matter of fact is
um in the past couple of years uh during
the
pandemic I had to I continued I didn't
stop teaching I was lucky enough that I
could still teach uh through Zoom with
uh the students that used CLA but I um I
actually continued teaching in person
with some of the actors that were in in
films so you know we got tested a lot
and almost every day and and we're care
we're
careful but the big change uh
challenging thing was that
behavior on physicality was
changing I felt for the first time that
people were really locked up in their
bodies probably it brought up a lot of
fear we were talking about fear but fear
at such level that I had never seen
before that's that that was one thing
the other thing that because I use my
hands and my voice and my whole body
that I felt that people were more
careful or more scared Ed with
physicality and that scared scared me
you know I said what is that what's
going on here and uh that was very very
challenging um and and the other thing
that was very challenging was the
psychological and
emotional uh
repercussions of co uh that I believe
that we haven't even began to realize
how this generation of young kids are
have been touched by Co you know uh
there there's a lot of fear and
um and the social the social fiber you
know that there's a lot of fear in terms
of um the
violence and the Judgment that people
have and the separation ations that are
going on and and it's still going on now
you know how how the you know the
government is um some some some states
are dealing with women for example is
terrifying and it and and it does have
an
impact physical psychological impact and
that so I I had to face it several
times and um and it was uh definitely a
learning curve for for me you know maybe
because I'm so sensitive in that area
and you believe in touch and human
communication I uh not only do I believe
it I I I I know I know it it is
necessary and uh that's why I'm I'm I'm
I'm concerned with the repercussions the
health repercussion question for these
young people you know how are they going
to deal with their lives forward you
know how do they and and um I'm not sure
that you it's not only a psychological
thing it has to be a physical thing they
need to um learn to trust
again you know the physical
contact and even before the pandemic do
you think there's certain uh cultures or
upbringings where people are not
comfortable with touch oh for sure for
sure I mean uh you know I grew up in the
Middle East I mean I was born in the
middle so the Middle East is very much
more conservative and uh uh somewhat
taboo to to you know to touch so that
but but on the other hand I will say
that I know a lot of people from the
Middle East that are very comfortable
with being touched
well yes if they're family and things
like that yes yes yes but there there
yeah it's it's a problem and how do you
deal with that in a class if you can
sense that someone's uncomfortable but
you don't want to the way you do it is
so beautiful you I I create an
environment that is very safe and I ask
them I I say you
know I'm going to put my hands here for
this purpose and if you don't if you are
not comfortable please tell me and I'll
figure out a different way of doing it
so I'm very flexible with it you know so
sometimes I'll make a game out of it
where I'm not touching them at all but
maybe I can have them touch themselves
you know or maybe have a student touch
them if they're more comfortable with
that so so yeah they they're their uh
their ways of doing it but you have to
respect you have to create an
environment you know a um a space that
it's absolutely safe you know and and um
and that people feel that they're
listened to and but even when you do
that still there will
be someone that will feel um
miscommunicated
with you know it's it's
fascinating